[Music]
very proud it's been 20 years since
edward james olmos played Abraham
Quintanilla in salina what do you
remember about that time of your life
filming that movie it was the status
field we have ever filmed to be honest
again I've never had a more difficult
film to to film it was too close to the
time when she was actually killed it's
only 13 months after we were filming and
nobody wanted to film it the parents
didn't we didn't nobody wanted to we
would rather she be alive but we had to
there was about four films being done at
the same time there was three
documentaries for documentaries and
books being written about her so the
family took it upon themselves to tell
the stories we got to be more Mexican
than the Mexicans and more American than
Americans but at the same time it's
exhausting ET spoke with the 70 year old
Oscar nominee at the Eva Longoria
Foundation's annual dinner it feels like
a really good time for Latinos in
Hollywood why are you so proud to be a
dominating voice I'm just proud of my
culture there wasn't enough of us at the
very beginning when I started you know
fifty years ago there was no one not
doing this at least everything that
Ava's done has been immense and I really
appreciate her the bottom of my heart
you
[Music]